[Musique]
le comité de suivi plurifon composé des
collectivités départementales et
régionales ainsi que de l'État s'est
réunies ce vendredi 7 avril dans
l'hémicycle du Palais de la source pour
examiner l'état d'avancement des fonds
européens le FEDER le FSE plus et le
fait ADR la mise en œuvre des programmes
européens pour la période
2021-2027 a été acté par la Convention
Cadre de gestion partenariale pour la
Réunion signée par le premier
vice-président du département Serge
Hoarau le préfet de la Réunion Jérôme
philippini et le premier vice-président
du conseil régional Patrick Lebreton
alors c'est un moment important puisque
ce comité régional de suivi des fonds
européens plurifont donc vient dacter et
valider les différents critères
d'attribution des différentes
subventions que ce soit au niveau du
FEDER du fs+ et du fait ADR fait adhère
qui est géré par le Conseil
départemental qui est l'autorité de
gestion c'est un moment important
puisque à partir du moment où cet
instant pas acté et pris acte de ces
critères de sélection nous allons
maintenant pouvoir ouvrir les nouveaux
programmes européens aux différents
bénéficiaires et pour ce qui concerne le
Conseil départemental dès la semaine
prochaine les premières fiches actions
seront activées notamment les fiches
actions pour lesquelles il n'y avait
plus d'argent sur l'ancien programme et
au fur et à mesure que nous finirons le
programme de
2014-2022 nous ouvrirons les nouvelles
fiches mesures 23 27 ce qui veut dire
que nous allons encore travailler
pendant quelques mois sur l'ancien
programme et le nouveau programme
démarre dès la semaine prochaine dès le
12 avril concernant la période 2023 2027
une enveloppe de 260 millions d'euros a
été attribué pour la mise en oeuvre du
faitader ces fonds permettront au
département de poursuivre le soutien au
développement rural avec neuf objectifs
prioritaires parmi lesquels
l'amélioration de la compétitivité des
exploitations agricoles ou encore la
préservation des ressources naturelles
et de la biodiversité
[Musique]